[Music]
the race to find that Titanic tour is
submersible this Tuesday night our crews
are working around the clock the
desperate and difficult search and how
much air is left for the five people on
board
Canada's military in mourning the
investigation into a deadly Chopper
crash near Ottawa
from fire to flooding I've never seen
this much rain and this much flooding
before the Alberta communities that
can't catch a break
and our crystal commencing inside a
Ukrainian military operating room we can
do one surgery from 8 A.M to 5 a.m the
doctors and nurses risking their lives
to save lives
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha good
evening and thanks for joining us after
two days of searching there is still no
sign of the Titanic tour submersible
missing in the North Atlantic we don't
know if the vessel is under water or
somewhere on the surface it's a race
against the clock with less than 40
hours of oxygen left for the five
passengers on board the Expedition left
St John's on Friday June 16th it arrived
at the surface above the Titanic wreck
site on Sunday and started its descent
early that morning about an hour and 45
minutes into the dive the mothership the
polar Prince lost all communication with
the vessel around 9 15 PM the Coast
Guard was notified and search efforts
began
this is a very complex search and the
unified team is working around the clock
to bring all available assets and
expertise to bear as quickly as possible
in an effort to solve this very complex
problem
the Urgent search is underway in the
North Atlantic off the coast of
Newfoundland and Labrador Mike Armstrong
is in St John's Mike this is a huge
operation involving Canadian and
American resources this is a massive
search effort basically out of several
places on the East Coast aircraft and
ships are set out from North Carolina
and Rhode Island but St John's here in
Newfoundland is really the closest to
the search area where about 640
kilometers out so it's become sort of a
staging area for important equipment
that's needed to come and then be sent
out but getting it out there as quickly
as possible is vital
these were the last photos taken of the
Titan Sunday before it Dove it was
launched from The Vessel the polar
Prince the team on that ship lost
contact less than two hours into the
dive I'm nervous I'm sick to my stomach
with nerves yonica Mickelson is a friend
of one of the men believed to be missing
British billionaire and Explorer Hamish
Harding there is hope but there is also
creeping pessimism as it stands right
now it would be a miracle if they are
recovered alive it's just starting to
dawn on me about what a tragedy this
really is oceanographer David Gallo has
worked on searches for missing planes
and ships he's with RMS Titanic the
company that owns the Salvage rights to
Titanic but he's also close personal
friends with another of the missing
French Maritime expert Paul Ari narzole
is often called Mr Titanic he's had the
most Dives to Titanic studied at the
longest and uh
one of the nicest guys you could ever
meet this is not a tourist operation no
Stockton Rush was piloting the Titan
he's the CEO of the company that runs
the submarine trips Ocean Gate
Expeditions Rush was often asked about
safety he would say if you want to be
safe don't get out of bed the other two
men missing are from one of Pakistan's
wealthiest families
and his son Suleiman our crews are
working around the clock now the search
is being led by the U.S Coast Guard out
of Boston it includes a Canadian C-130
and a Canadian p8 aircraft with
underwater sonar capability that's one
of the challenges Searchers have to look
both on the surface and below the
surface
now the timing of when the Titans
stopped communicating may be a clue to
what happened one of the dangers of the
dive was getting snagged on the Titanic
wreck but an hour and 45 minutes in the
Titan wouldn't yet have been close to
the wreck it would however have been
under incredible amounts of pressure
making an implosion a possibility they
probably weren't at the bottom yet
which probably means it wasn't being
snagged and you know that leaves an
issue with the pressure Hull which would
be frightening
now that vessel the submarine has a
shelf life the pressurization and
depressurization over and over takes a
toll on it there is something called a
cyclic fatigue that can happen to the
Halt and basically at that depth any
little problem with the hull would be
fatal nithu now Mike you mentioned St
John's is being used as a staging area
what other resources are on their way
yeah there are several ships actually on
their way here and also on the way to
the site one ship that arrived at the
site already is the Deep energy that has
some ability to look deep another ship
that's on the way is a French vessel the
Adelante that ship has a remote
controlled submarine that can go down
unmanned all the way to the ocean floor
to look around that said that ship is 48
hours away and time is very much of the
essence you too
is indeed Mike Armstrong in St John's
Newfoundland and Labrador thanks Mike
the New York Times reports experts
warned of significant concerns about the
vessel several years ago Crews have
already searched an area more than
twenty thousand square kilometers to try
and find the Titan it's about the size
of a large SUV and is designed for deep
Dives Eric Sorensen tells us more about
the vessel and what it's like inside
the Titan submersible is a high-tech
capsule built to withstand immense
pressure several tons per inch at the
depth of the Titanic that was
co-designed with NASA David Pogue of CBS
once made the dive with Ocean Gate
Founders stocked in rush and while the
capsule is Ultra Modern he was struck by
the improvisation of some equipment I
got these from uh Camper World We Run
the whole thing with this game
controller so how prepared is the craft
or Rescuers if the sub snagged in
fishing nets are lost all power the
extreme cold total darkness and crushing
pressure at depths most submarines
cannot navigate not even radar Works
they can't have a line tethering it all
the way down because it'll be too heavy
and too much drag so it's really a bit
like a moon shot the sub is about seven
meters long the crew entered by the
titanium cap with the viewport and they
were bolted in cannot get out themselves
even if they surface inside it's about
the size of a minivan and five people
with snacks a little bit of water but
only enough air to breathe it's
estimated for about another day and a
half there are many ways to the surface
the mystery for those who've been down
there if it hasn't already surfaced
somewhere why hasn't it it has different
kinds of ballast stick and let go it has
an inflatable air bladder it has
propellers
so why isn't it at the surface Ron toygo
went down on the Titan once and
Communications were lost for a couple of
hours but he says the crew was fully
prepped when you go there you're
prepared for all this like they're they
don't hide anything they tell you at a
virtually you know all these number of
things but toygo is worried it's really
the families that that uh you gotta have
you know feel for right now the Coast
Guard says it's sending all available
resources but there's no certainty the
sub can be brought up from the depths
this is a complex case and uh the Coast
Guard doesn't have all the resources to
be able to affect uh this kind of uh
rescue the French are sending a deep
submersible for what would be a miracle
rescue beneath the surface you're not
going to be able to transfer them onto
another vessel with depth you're gonna
have to bring the whole submersible up
to attach something to them to help
bring it up
and then extract them that's all going
to take a lot of time and what Rescuers
do not have is a lot of time
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
later on global national we'll hear more
from Tim Malton the Titanic expert on
the possible conditions aboard the
submersible and some of the biggest
challenges ahead for this immense rescue
operation
two members of the Royal Canadian Air
Force are feared dead and two others are
injured after a Chinook helicopter
crashed in Ontario the aircraft went
down in the Ottawa river near Garrison
Petawawa just after midnight our
Mercedes Stevenson is at the base
following the developments Mercedes
Nita we have been watching the parade of
very somber and sad faces leaving this
base as colleagues worry about those two
missing individuals who have still not
been identified by the military we have
seen Vehicles entering the base from the
Ontario Provincial Police that are
titled underwater search and Recovery
Unit on his way into question period
today prime minister Justin Trudeau
surprised reporters by stating that some
members of the Canadian Armed Forces had
died in the crash
I was happy to speak with the chief of
Defense Staff last night to express my
condolences on on the families and and
colleagues of the members who've been
killed
neither the military certainly wasn't
expecting the prime minister to break
that news and they still have not
confirmed that those two members are
dead although they've updated their
language to call this a search and
Recovery operation instead of search and
rescue military sources tell me that's
partially because the military has a
policy of not declaring people deceased
until the missing have actually been
recovered okay and Mercedes how are
these helicopters used and what was the
air crew training for
so I'm told that this is a fairly
typical night training exercise they
were going up the Ottawa River that is a
common insertion point for troops to
practice to deliver for example key
equipment or to deliver up to 30 crew
that can be on board that soldiers that
will be inserted somewhere and the
nighttime part is because Western
militaries actually have an advantage at
night because they have night vision
goggles we still don't know the details
of what actually happened in this crash
but there will be a full investigation
into it it is the Workhorse of the
military Fleet I spoke with Jason Arthur
who's a former pilot on a chinook and
this is what he told us about the
situation in the community today
the military is a very close-knit group
and family and you know event like this
definitely will shake everyone to the
core and I know they'll do everything
they can to investigate this and make
sure that they are able to prevent it
from happening again
either at this hour the Chinook fleet
has not been grounded but what
something the military is looking into
and we are waiting for updates on what
has happened to those two missing
members of its crew all right Mercedes
Stevenson in Petawawa Ontario thanks for
this Mercedes
albertans going from one extreme to
another coming up the torrential rain
ravaging communities recently threatened
by wildfires
weather conditions in parts of Alberta
have gone from one extreme to another
residents who've just returned from
Wildfire evacuations west of Edmonton
are now faced with floods Global's
Morgan black is in Piers Alberta tonight
Morgan
nithu the backyard of this home in
Pierce Alberta is almost completely
submerged the homeowner says he watched
as it rained and reigned and his
property line disappeared
it's like this throughout the Hamlet
west of Edmonton people in the South
area of Pierce were ordered to shelter
in place Tuesday morning because of
heavy rain Rising water and a bridge
that can't be crossed because the water
is compromising the bank emergency
responders are helping to get people out
of the area as it experiences water
levels most residents have never seen on
Monday evening an evacuation order was
issued for residents in the nearby lower
Rob area Edson got a lot of rain too
mayor Kevin Zahara says the town is
working through a number of challenges
there is the risk of contamination with
water people's basements have sewage in
them some of our Creeks may have sewage
in them so we're asking people to stay
out of those areas making sure that
they're taking the appropriate safety
precautions I've never seen it this
flooded and I've been here 19 years this
is the first time I've seen it this high
it was Mother Nature getting back at us
it's even harder people say knowing this
is the rain they desperately needed when
the county was dealing with wildfire
nithu
all right Morgan black and Piers Alberta
thanks Morgan
lives on the line ahead medical experts
work around the clock at a Ukrainian
Hospital
[Music]
foreign
Sirens wailed across Ukraine's Capital
early this morning as Russia launched a
widespread Air Assault the three-hour
bombardment targeted several cities from
the front lines in the East to as far
west as La Vive Ukraine says it shot
down nearly all 35 attack drones no
deaths were reported we don't fully know
how many Ukrainian soldiers have died
since Russia's full-scale Invasion began
more than a year ago or how many people
have been wounded Global News was
recently granted access to a military
Hospital in the Kiev region Crystal
commencing and video journalist Braden
Latham observed several surgeries and
spoke with the team's test with saving
lives and a warning some of the video is
graphic
Ukrainian medical professionals are
becoming some of the most skilled and
knowledgeable in combat medicine the
expertise however comes at a price when
we work on a wound and in operation room
we just concentrate it and do what we
must do after work with and thinking
about different stuff
it then we have a set emotions but now
we must do and to keep calm Dr ihor
lashkin is good at keeping calm Global
News was granted access to a military
Hospital in the Kiev region and observed
the traumatologist working to repair a
fractured tibia it's a it's a not a big
injury actually shrapnel wounds limbs
torn apart by mines organs damaged by
bullets staff here have seen it all
the staff in this facility say they are
working around the clock if they have a
couple of minutes they sit down get some
food and then they're back at it
obviously
three operations were simultaneously
underway when we were on site nurses and
medical staff ping-ponged from Supply
rooms into the operating areas Direction
shouted and different songs could be
heard coming from small speakers a
well-choreographed dance in a small
space it's very great honest to uh use
my knowledge of help our guys
most of the patients here are Ukrainian
Soldiers with catastrophic injuries but
there are also doctors injured while
working near the front lines we were
told the man who was rushed past our
camera on the stretcher is a doctor who
lost both legs we're not revealing the
location of this facility or showing any
identifying markers too often they've
become targets the World Health
Organization verified more than one
thousand attacks on Health Care
Facilities since Russia's full invasion
began some days Dr loshkin performs 10
operations other days he tackles just
one complex case we can do one surgery
from 8 AM to
5 am all day all night here so you just
you just keep going
away from the busy or we meet stepan
barabash he's here getting follow-up
care for his back and arm after spending
weeks in a different hospital in the
southeast
the 47-year-old was injured during a
mortar attack in buckmut the location of
one of the longest and bloodiest battles
of the war
it's especially scary at night during
shelling he says they use incendiary
shells everything glows and there's a
feeling that you are in Hell everything
everywhere Burns
for most who end up here the priority is
returning to the battlefield not rest
and Recovery the Medical Teams stitching
them back together are working for the
benefit of their patient but also their
country
Bristol convincing global news keep
region Ukraine
[Music]
next Titanic expert Tim Bolton on the
challenges of finding the missing
[Music]
returning now to our top story the
search for the missing Titanic tourists
submersible in the North Atlantic and
the Race Against Time to find the five
people on board for further Insight I'm
joined by Titanic expert and author Tim
Malton from London Tim thank you so much
for doing this I want to start with your
reaction to all of this what's running
through your mind now into the third day
since the submersible made contact
well we're all hoping and praying that a
miracle will happen and that in fact
these these poor people will be found
safe and well before they run out of
oxygen
um however
um it does seem that unless the
submersible has made it to the surface
uh where it could just about in daylight
hours be spotted
um fortuitously by a helicopter search
helicopter passing overhead if that
happens then there's a there's a chance
but if they're down on the seabed
possibly snagged in a fishing net or
something that's got caught in the
wreckage then um I really don't know
that there are any other submarines that
can go down that deep that have the
capability to recover the submarine with
the stricken people on board right and
you haven't been to the Titanic yourself
but as an expert on the wreckage can you
give us an idea of what kind of
conditions people would face at those
depths well I mean the first thing to
say is that it's 400 times the pressure
of the atmosphere which is absolutely
astronomically High it takes two and a
half hours to descend slowly down to the
seabed when you land it's kind of soft
mud it's also pitch black and it's
freezing cold down there so you're
relying on your batteries for light and
also to light the wreckage that you're
looking at or even the seabed and you're
relying on the electricity to keep you
slightly warm as well what are some of
the biggest challenges around trying to
mount a rescue operation
well the first thing is that the Titanic
sank even even by the standards of 1912
um when when she sank 111 years ago she
sank in the middle of nowhere so she's a
long long way from Land uh she's in a
very deep part of the ocean that's two
and a half miles down and
um obviously there's a lot of bad
weather and things around there that
that they've had recently so
um it's it's not just like finding a
needle in a a haystack you've also got
to think that radar doesn't work at
depth so you've only got sonar so really
um it's a very very difficult rescue
our understanding is that it takes about
two and a half hours for this Ocean Gate
submersible to get down to the Titanic
but communication loss was reported
about an hour and a half into the
journey what do you make of that yes
that is slightly odd but I was speaking
to a gentleman earlier today who
actually had been on the previous Ocean
Gate Expedition and worryingly he said
that it was not infrequent for
communication to be lost from time to
time between the submersible and what
I'm calling the mothership as it were so
it does seem that this technology was a
little bit shaky I want to ask you about
this the New York Times is reporting
that back in 2018 a letter was written
to Ocean Gate warning of possible quote
catastrophic problems with the
submersibles development and its planned
mission to the Titanic wreckage how safe
do you think this exploration is
well I think the answer to that is it's
not as safe as we all thought and hoped
it would be I mean we've all done things
like I don't know bungee jumping or
whatever it is when one has to sign
one's life away so one's kind of used to
signing these these waivers but in fact
I'm sure that when the father and the 19
year old boy who is or young man I
should say who was on the submersible
I'm sure when they signed their waivers
um I'm sure they thought that they were
coming back right that is Titanic expert
and author Tim Moulton Tim thank you
very much for your Insight
my pleasure
and that is global national for this
Tuesday night I'm nitu Garcia this is St
John's Harbor in Newfoundland and
Labrador the staging area for the search
of the missing Titan submersible and its
five crew members thanks so much for
watching Donna will be back at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]